ببدء تنفيذ هذه الضربات كما ذكر مسؤولون
امريكيون ضربات
انتقاميه حسب قولهم في ضد مواقع عديده في
سوريا والعراق وهناك حديث عن سته مواقع
نقلا عن مسؤول في
البنتاجون يعني سلمى كما شاهدنا في
العواجل التي نقلناها وكانت تسريبا
تسريبات لمسؤولين امريكيين وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه هذه الضربات تحتل اهميه كبرى
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هنا في الب
بيت الابيض هناك صمت تام حتى اللحظه كما
ذكرنا لا يوجد اعلان رسمي حتى اللحظه
تواصلنا منذ بدء اولى
الضربات مع مجلس الامن القومي هنا في
البيت الابيض حتى اللحظه لا يوجد تاكيد
لنا من قبل مجلس الامن القومي بانها بدات
بالفعل عاده كما ذكرنا في السابق سلمى
عاده الرئيس الامريكي يصدر بيانا يصرح فيه
عن بدء ضربات او عن توجيه وزير الدفاع
ل الرد على اي هجوم تتعرض له القوات
الامريكيه وايضا يتبع ذلك بيان من وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه حتى اللحظه لم يصدر اي
من هذين البيانين حقيقه وهو امر غير معتاد
ولكن المؤكد بان هناك ضربات ك نقاشات داخل
البيت الابيض عن طبيعه هذه الضربات وحدود
هذه
الضربات خبرينا اكثر عن طبيعه هذه
النقاشات التي سادت البيت الابيض بشان هذه
الضربات خاصه في الساعات الاخيره قبيل
حدوثها نعم هذه النقاشات سلمى كانت على
مدار ثلاثه ايام للرئيس بايدن مع كبار
مستشاريه بمجلس الامن القومي من جيك
سوليفان مستشار للامن القومي وزير الدفاع
الامريكي كان في تلك الاجتماعات مديره
الاستخبارات القوميه افرل هينز ل مناقشه
المعلومات التحليليه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه وما اذا كانت ايران هي التي
اعطت الضوء الاخضر للجماعات او الميليشيات
المسلحه بتوجيه هذه المسيره التي اسفرت عن
مقتل ثلاثه جنود امريكيين وايضا عدد اخر
من المسؤولين الرئيس بايدن حقيقه
هناك جانب او سياق سياسي للرد الامريكي
بحيث ان بايدن ليس بحاجه لتوسيع دائره
الصراع في البيت الابيض هذا اخر شيء
يتمناه الرئيس امريكي وهو يخوض عاما
انتخابيا كذلك اكد البيت الابيض اكثر من
مره بانه ابدا لا يسعى الى اي صراع او
مواجهه عسكريه مع ايران وذكر مسؤولون اكثر
من مره بان الرد الامريكي سوف يكون حصرا
في سوريا والعراق ويستهدف تلك الجماعات
التي تزودها ايران ب السلاح والتي تهاجم
القوات الامريكيه والسؤال الكبير حقيقه
سلمى الان ما اذا كانت الضربات الامريكيه
التي ستتم على مراحل كما ذكرنا خلال هذه
التغطيه كافيه لردع هذه الجماعات او
الميليشيات عن القيام بالمزيد من الهجمات
ضد القوات الامريكيه ام لا خاصه كما ذكرنا
بان الحرب على غزه لا تحظى باي شعبيه هنا
في الولايات المتحده اكثر من نصف
الامريكيين بحسب استطلاع الراي لاسوس بريس
ومؤسسه ابحاث صدر اليوم قال ان اكثر من
نصف الامريكيين يعتقدون بان اسرائيل بالغت
وتجاوزت الحد في ردها على هذه الحرب
311% فقط من الامريكيين يؤيدون اداء
الرئيس بايدن في هذه الحرب ومهما كانت
حقيقه تصريحات المسؤولين في البيت الابيض
عن استطلاعه الراي فهي ما زالت حقيقه مهمه
لاي رئيس يترشح لولايه ثانيه